good morning believe nation today's
messages business must serve a higher
purpose over you Mukesh Ambani my father
was a big believer that any business
that has the sole purpose of making
money is not worth doing right
business must serve a larger societal
purpose
I love love-love-love this message
because I think every business has the
duty to give back to their community and
not just hey let's make a lot of money
and then give it to charity but in the
process of running your business
providing value right remember you're
making money because you're providing
value the more value provide to to
clients the more money you're gonna make
and companies who have a goal
entrepreneurs will have a goal of just
trying to make money rarely make it once
the guys who want to have an impact the
guys who want to change the world in a
positive way somehow the guys have this
big vision for what they think could
happen in the world and they want to be
a part of that they want to be one of
the people changing and shaping future
of a certain industry those are the guys
who end up winning and and by winning
them by changing that's how you make a
lot of money - because you're focused on
creating products and services that
people are really going to find
interesting helpful and news and it's
great to want to give back I find
sometimes often entrepreneurs would give
back too soon like you have to be able
to keep yourself going right you have to
be able to make money yourself and pay
your bills while providing extreme value
to other companies and don't just give
away money to charity and that's a great
cause but first you have to make sure
that you are still around and able to
keep on contributing and so I would
encourage you to think about two things
okay one how can you in the process of
the product or service that you're
reading have a big impact big goal that
you want to change your industry and
have a positive contribution on the
world and then to how can you do
something more local more in the
community a passion project something
that you love when you're excited about
so in my case my examples every time I
sell some
so for example here I'm at Sage summit
right you can see the sign behind me you
got the crazy thunderstorm happen above
me hopeful the audience coming out okay
they pay me to be here right I'm being
paid to be here but I'm not just here
selling well I'm not selling anything
for me I'm not saying hey go buy my book
go buy my t-shirts sign up for my
mastermind group I'm not selling
anything I'm just here to provide value
I'm providing value because I generally
want entrepreneurs to get better I
genuinely care what entrepreneurs
hopefully that comes across in a YouTube
channel and I want them to get better
and that's why they pay me to come here
and the more I focus on that the more I
actually end up helping entrepreneurs
and the Mormon vited to come back and do
more of this stuff what I came on and
said hey you guys gotta all go buy my
book sure I might make some extra
short-term sales of my book summaries
ooh good guides but they're never gonna
invite me back and so I'm playing the
long-term game on top of that I also
have donated nickel for a hundred
thousand dollars now it's a Kiva which
supports entrepreneurs in Africa so as
part of doing business with me money
that we make goes to support
entrepreneurs who are trying to build a
better life for themselves enough and in
that that's inspiring both of them like
dealing with a today entrepreneurs and
knowing that what I'm doing is helping
other people makes me want to keep going
helps me get more business helps me get
more media attention but more
importantly the right thing to do and
when you're doing something powerful
positive and and has the ability to make
a lot of impact then you're gonna get a
lot of recognition you're gonna get a
lot of attention you're gonna make a lot
of money and hopefully change the world
thank you guys so much for watching my
question today for you today is what
higher purpose is your business sir I'm
really curious to find out leave it in
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe
have an amazing day and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
I've been semester
Spray so keep me going